你是不是也想搞懂到底要怎么掌握交易心理学
今天我们就来好好拆解一下知名交易员巨人杰他的思维框架
来看看他是怎么样战胜自己内心那个最大的敌人
也就是所谓的心魔
并且建立起一套完全是靠理性的交易逻辑
好在我们开始之前我想先问大家一个问题
你有没有过这种经验
就是盯着那个交易账户的数字
然后脑子里就开始换算
这次亏的钱
哇可以买台车了耶
或者赚的这些等于我好几个月的薪水了
如果你曾经有过这种念头
那今天我们要聊的
你肯定会觉得说到心坎里了
好那我们就先从第一部分开始看
交易者的心魔
俊仁杰认为在交易里面最难搞定的
其实根本不是市场的张张跌跌
而是我们自己心里面的那个声音
这个所谓的心魔啊
说穿了就是我们很自然的
会把账户里的数字
跟现实生活中的东西连接在一起
你想想看哦
当你脑子里想的是
我亏掉的是一台车
而不是我亏掉了多少点数
那个感觉完全不一样对吧
恐惧一下就上来了
然后呢
你可能就会做出一些非理性的决定
反过来也一样哦
当你觉得
哇我赚到一个月的薪水了
这个时候贪婪就跑出来了
可能就会让你
忘了原本设定好的策略
那该怎么办
要怎么战胜这个心魔呢
巨人杰给的答案其实非常直接
你必须彻彻底底的转变你的心态
把交易就当成是一场数字游戏
我觉得张投影片真的很有趣
他把解决问题的第一步讲得非常清楚
就是把金钱数位化你不要再去想你赚赔了多少钱而是要专注在这些数字代表的点数或百分比的变化说真的
不管是赚一百万还是一百块
你背后的操作逻辑
应该要完全一模一样才对
没错
这个比喻简直是完美
你想想看你在打电动的时候
你不会因为损失几分百
就心痛到不行吧
你只会想说
功率是怎样
我要怎么把分数打回来
交易就应该是这样
把那些恐惧啊贪婪啊
从你的决策过程里面彻底的拔掉
为了在实际操作的时候
真的能做到这个心态
巨人节就提出了一个非常经典的比喻
他称之为养乐多理论
我们来看一个很经典的状况哦
比方说你在50块买进一个东西
因为你的判断是
嗯他的供给出了点问题
很可能会缺货
结果呢
它居然先跌到40块
这时候你看到账面上的亏损
心里就觉得
哇超痛了
然后为了赶快结束这个痛苦
你就把它卖掉了
结果呢
它后来一路涨到200块
你看哦
你一开始的逻辑其实完全正确
但你却被那个40块的短暂痛苦给打败了
所以啊
这个养乐多理论的核心其实很简单
就是只要你当初进场的那个理由没有消失
你就根本不应该被中间的价格波动给吓跑
好啦心态我们调整好了
但是交易的点子到底要从哪里来
难道是靠什么很神秘的技术指标吗
嘿答案是完全不是
根据巨人节的说法
所有的交易机会都来自一个最根本的经济原则
就是供需失衡
所以你的任务不是去猜市场
而是要像个侦探一样
在我们的现实生活里面
去找到那些
好像快要引发工需变化的线索
像这个台风的例子就讲得非常清楚了当气象局发布台风警报这就是一个线索你的逻辑应该是去预判蔬菜供给会减少哦
而不是等到新闻都爆出来说
农损多惨重菜价飙涨了
你才去反应
真正的机会永远都在于提前解决
这个逻辑你把它放到金融市场上
那就更明显了
市场交易的永远都是预期
比方说一家记忆体公司宣布说
要减产
就算当下产品的价格
根本还没动
但它的股价会立刻上涨
为什么
因为所有人都已经预期到
未来的供给会变少
好
那问题就来了
当你在生活中观察到这些线索之后
你到底要怎么验证你的想法是对的
但又不用冒着赔光身家的巨大风险呢
这就是巨人节整个方法论最核心的部分了
叫做一张试单理论
意思就是说
不管你的想法听起来有多么天衣无缝
你都先用市场能够接受的最小单位
比方说一张股票
甚至一股也可以
先去测试一下
这个方法最厉害最精髓的地方
就是它把交易很明确的切成了两个阶段
你看哦
第一个阶段目标完全不是赚钱
而是验证逻辑
看看你的想法市场买不买单
只有当你的逻辑被证明是对的之后
你才进入第二个阶段
开始去想说
好那我要怎么赚取利润
没错
这个疫苗的比喻
真的是太贴切了
你绝对不会在一个配方
还没有被证实有效之前
就把所有资源都投进去量产吧
交易也是一样的道理
透过这样小小的试单
你就把交易从一场赌博
变成了一个很科学的验证过程
好
那如果我们的目标
不是要求每一笔交易都一定要赢
那这整套系统
它最终极的目标到底是什么答案就是追求正的期望值这个观念的转变真的非常非常关键重点已经不在于你赢了几次
而是在于
你赢的时候可以赚多少
跟你输的时候会赔多少
你的目标就是要让平均赚的钱
远远大于平均赔的钱
我们直接看这张图
这个概念就非常清楚了
你看左边的策略A
胜率高达八成
哇听起来很棒对不对
但他每次都只赚一点点
再看看右边的策略B
胜率很低哦
可能十次里面输掉七次
但是只要他赢了一次
那个利用就大到可以把所有亏损都补回来
还有胜
所以长期来看
策略B其实远比策略A更赚钱
这就是高期望值的威力
没错
那些创投基金
他们就是玩期望值游戏的专家
他们根本不在乎投的十家新创公司里面到了九家
他们真正在乎的是那一家成功的公司
能不能变成下一个Google或下一个台积电
这就提醒我们在交易里面
你应该优先去找那些潜在回报非常巨大的机会
而不是那些只能让你小赚小赢的交易
好了我们来总结一下
你看这整个框架其实是还款商口的
第一步调整形态
把钱当作分数
这样你才能克服心魔
再来从生活里面去观察工序的变化
找到你的交易逻辑
然后用一张单的科学方法去验证这个逻辑
而你最终的目标不是追求百分之百的胜率
而是要追求一个长期正向的期望值
所以今天听完这个解说之后
下一次当你又要做出交易决策的时候
不妨停下来问问自己
我现在这个动作是来自于对亏损的恐惧
还是来自于我一开始建立的那个清清楚楚的逻辑
我想这个答案将会决定一切